esta es radio canadá internacional
bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
café o el castor cibernético una emisión
producida por la sección en español del
difusor público radio canadá
internacional difundimos en directo cada
viernes a las dos y cuarto por las redes
sociales en internet en esta emisión
conversamos sobre los temas destacados
de la semana y damos lectura a sus
comentarios y correos electrónicos
este programa se encuentra disponible en
nuestro sitio en internet eres en este
punto sea nuestro correo electrónico es
hablar
heresi net punto sea y hoy estamos en
los micrófonos con ustedes
pablo gómez leonora y leonardo jiménez
hola en la versión radio de este
programa disponible en tu sitio internet
escucharemos al músico canadiense
michael bublé al marfileño tiken jah
fakoly y también a la que ve quien si
isabel pies con la canción letra bom
entonces creo que ese es el título con
que podemos comenzar este programa todo
el mundo disfrutando del calor aunque
hay noticias de que inclusive se
avecinan huracanes de categoría 6 así
que donde las veces avecinan ahora ya
hubo uno ya hubo uno que pasó bueno no
fue un huracán fue una tormenta tropical
que pasó allá cerca de terranova pero no
tengo conocimiento de que haya para que
estén alineados acá con que ver según
los cálculos que se han hecho las
proyecciones meteorológicas en los
cambios climáticos van a crearse nuevos
fenómenos por ejemplo como la categoría
6 que no existe
así que está muy bien ahora hablas de
eso desde que se avecina
este es un se establece que eso esto se
va a producir en las próximas décadas y
justamente con proyecciones como esquema
de un montón de condiciones que tienen
que dar la historia es que si seguimos
al paso que vamos se van a dar las
condiciones para que esto pueda ocurrir
y también se nos va a ocurrir no sabemos
si va a ocurrir en las dimensiones que
vos decís o sea hace 20 años se hablaba
de huracanes con con cierta consecución
en la parte donde se producen los
huracanes hoy en día y se están dando
pero no con las mismas
de los mismos vaticinios que acciones de
20 años evidentemente son probabilidades
son son todos los esquemas
probabilísticos de cosas que pueden
pasar si se dan ciertas cosas si se dan
ciertas condiciones es ahora lo que sí
se está avecinando es un ice ver
impresionante en groenlandia se está
como desprendiendo un bloque que hay que
hay que verlo porque ese es el inmenso y
están científicos ahí en groenlandia hay
una alerta porque hay una comunidad de
que vive cerca donde se va a pasar se
supone este icebergs y al libro sí pero
si se llega a separar y porque ya cayó
un poco de hielo y dice que ha creado
unas olas impresionantes imagínate si
este gran pedazo css se abre y están
hablando de una población de 108
personas de intuit que viven en esa muy
cerca donde está hace icebergs y lo que
estuve mirando es una científica
canadiense que trabaja en la universidad
de nueva york con su esposo estuvieron
en ese lugar están en ese lugar
filmado el desprendía y afirmó el
desprendimiento un desprendimiento
enorme que cuando lo miré hoy dije eso
es un fenómeno que yo nunca he visto el
hielo que va desprendiendo se pregunta
parte que va cayendo y va levantando el
agua helada
y con pedazos de hielo y una fuerza eso
sí que da miedo vivir cerca dibujar o
habría que prestar a nuestros amigos
oyentes qué es lo que está notando en
sus regiones que se nota por ejemplo en
la patagonia me imagino que también de
ver cambios climáticos allá claro la
antártida también está sufriendo este
derretimiento y muy acelerado en nuestro
tipo de fenómenos que son más locales
que uno no los ve porque uno está atento
a los a los grandes fenómenos por por
ejemplo nosotros vivimos en la ciudad
san luís en la ciudad de san luis era un
lugar seco
hasta hace 15 o 20 años atrás yo el
digamos el tema de que era seco era por
mi padre sufría de asma entonces él
trabajaba en un banco y lo el clima lo
anunciaba exacto y lo trasladan a los
lugares secos sea el sur de mendoza san
luis santiago del estero puntualmente
con esas ciudades hemos vivido gracias a
ese fenómeno no trasladarlo al lugar
donde estuviera mejor para su salud y en
los últimos 15 o 20 años fue la humedad
es pura humedad o sea a la baja humedad
que es digamos más al noreste se ha
desplazado y ahora ocupa toda la parte
de salud se están produciendo vinos en
san luís
en realidad no tanto porque la humedad
no favorece al crecimiento del agua pero
a lo que voy es que hay el fenómeno es
mucho más local es que uno no tiene en
cuenta pero que también están
trastornando de alguna manera el
quehacer cotidiano la guía a este calor
que observamos está hace dos semanas eso
se nos pasó a nosotros aquí en montreal
y este calor que mató a cerca de 60
personas creo en quebec
no 70 llegó a 70 y generalmente son
personas de edad pues eso es un fenómeno
que lo estamos percibiendo nosotros bien
de cerquita algunos pues no lo lloran
tanto por ejemplo estuve leyendo de que
las viñas están felices porque la
producción de uvas para hacer vino va a
ser extraordinaria este año pero hay
otras frutas que pues se sufrieron ese
golpe de calor y sin hablar de los seres
humanos por supuesto entonces lo estamos
viviendo ya permanentemente
cotidianamente como dice también un poco
leonardo pero como decía horacio guarany
y si el vino viene viene la vida en las
otras generaciones viene antes de entrar
a los temas de que proponemos a nuestros
oyentes cada en cada programa hay
noticias que desean llamado la atención
por lo singular lo peculiar
anfel
y se cumple
feliz cumpleaños para las aplicaciones
explica las hicieron esta semana se
cumplen 10 años
la primera forma en realidad cuando se
empezaron a envidiamos a popularizar y
entraron en vigencia gracias a los
teléfonos inteligentes y los que son
micro programas no exacto exacto pero
nosotros antes hablábamos en todo caso
de pequeños programas pero nunca de app
las acciones como tal app se dice que
conoce a partir de dónde esta semana se
cumplen 10 años de que oficialmente se
empezaron a utilizar las app en los
teléfonos si no hay teléfonos sin apps
ahora no no podría en realidad comprar
al proveer casi todos los teléfonos del
encono el problema no puedes vivir sin
a mí me llamó la atención un poco a
nivel internacional de américa latina'
me sorprendió la decisión de lópez
obrador que todavía él va a asumir el
primero de diciembre pero ya está
actuando como presidente de mexico de
llevar a cabo unas reformas judiciales y
entre ellas lo que propone y que eso fue
dice que eso es lo que los mexicanos
quieren está dispuesto realmente a
combatir la corrupción y uno quiere
iniciar a crear nuevas leyes por ejemplo
hay una que va a salir cuando él estén
en su mandato y es que cualquier
presidente que sea sospechado de
corrupción puede ser juzgado y dejar el
cargo obligado a dejar el cargo cosa que
no existía no existe en mexico no sé en
otros países entonces el mismo se está
poniendo en el papel de ser juzgado si
él llega a cometer un acto ilegal lo
cual me gusta muchísimo esa actitud es
decir lópez obrador parece que va
va a cumplir en la medida de lo posible
pues parte de lo que de las promesas que
hizo durante su campaña electoral y son
es algo inaudito no es de nuevo y lo que
me llamó la atención a nivel canadiense
es este embrollo en que se metió el
primer ministro canadiense josh ha
entrado con esta acusación y yo creo que
vos hiciste algo pablo sobre eso de una
mujer hace 20 años en la cual se había
salido en un diario que él había tenido
una actitud inapropiada con una mujer y
que eso existió y que es bueno a él
tenía era tenía 20 años menos pero lo
que me llamó la atención no es eso sino
lo que me llamó es los son los
justificativos que todo utilizó porque
eso feminista a mí me gusta mucho su
posición que tiene desde hacer avanzar
pues la cuestión de las mujeres no me
olvido que cuando él asumió y eso fue un
algo inédito aquí la mitad de su
gabinete son mujeres y siguen siendo
mujeres y son además con cargos
políticos muy importantes como la la que
tiene la cartera
me llamó la atención como para ti no
para salir del entorno porque dijo bueno
en un momento dado dice las mujeres y
los hombres tenemos percepciones
diferentes no ahí como que no le entendí
muy bien lo que quiso decir y en segundo
lugar dijo buenos no sabía que era
periodista
muchísimo pero pero él se defendió de
esas acusaciones de acoso no existe sino
angoso pero lo que me sorprendió para
que viera que si hubiera sabido que era
periodista
pero finalmente esa parte se me escape
no la entendí muy bien y yo la entiendo
perfecto osea quiso decir que si tenía
una profesión que estaba en la palestra
no lo hubiera hecho
me llamó la atención de sentirse
culpable yo creo que uno de los
elementos bueno y este es mi reflexión
personal en el respecto
es que hubo un diputado no sé si se
acuerdan que fue tuvo que salirse del
partido que fue excluido y además de ser
[Música]
válido y que sí que fue acusado y al
parecer tenían razón de acoso sexual y
problemas entonces le tocó y justamente
yo creo que fue usted quien le pidió que
se retire se retirara visitarlo entonces
de repente sale un esqueleto en el
placard el viejo de 20 años no donde hay
acusaciones pero que no sé no entiendo
cómo fue que esa salió a flote esa
noticia historia alguien en otro no fue
firmado fueron declaraciones que se
hicieron y que lo que sucedió eso y fue
en columbia británica él era profesor en
una escuela no era el primer ministro
el ex primer ministro canadiense
y no se viene exactamente qué pasó pero
bueno en el caso es que esto se había
escrito en un periódico alguien sacó ese
periódico ahora lo trajeron y por alguna
razón evidentemente y no creo que hayan
sido los liberales que sacaron ese
artículo pero es la periodista en
cuestión pues la encontraron y salió a
declarar que efectivamente había pasado
eso y porque ya no quería hablar más
porque no no daba para más el tema es la
misma los errores ese punto es esencial
el hecho de que ella decide no llevar
adelante un proceso decide dejar la cosa
está como está y esto justamente lo que
interesante es ver para qué sirve porque
es al esta hora y es porque los
conservadores están ya en cámping
valentonadas además con las encuestas no
no seguro que esto salió de los
conservadores de sodio y con la victoria
de fueron en toronto en ontario entonces
el asa y esto lo encuentras pelando los
cuchillos a veces también el hecho de
corriendo para encontrar cosas
particiones garber viajes sin informar
al gobierno hasta dos nidos justo
después del momento
entra en vigor las que informa es un
ciudadano que está obligado a informar
digamos que la práctica corriente
desplazando los o las redes y quizás no
pero la gente debería además y profesión
seguridad hay por acción seguridad
generalmente se informa al gobierno le
informan al gobierno del pasado siempre
ha informado ahora pues te van a
presionar por es una criatura del snark
entonces él tiene su sus propósitos
seguramente no y lo fundamental es ver
cómo también hablábamos de esto como
todo el aparato conservador apoyo a la
fuerte en la provincia de ontario y
ganar ontario es casi ganar
entonces en este contexto habría que ver
si seguro seguro que viene de ellos no
no me imagino que pueda venir de otro de
otra tendencia u otro partido único todo
esto nos saludamos a nuestra gente
[Música]
en realidad tenemos a carlos tapia 15 de
donde nos dice dónde es carlos tapia y
gilberto martínez y saludos rodrigo nada
en las américas así que saludó si pueden
por favor a vecinos de donde nos están
viendo para que podamos justamente
hablar de sus regiones e imaginar el
clima en esas partes si lo que aquí hace
supuestamente calor afuera y en efecto
hace calor afirmó el aire acondicionado
está tan fuerte aquí en esta casa que a
muchos de vosotros os gusta jugar por sí
pero que a mí me congelan completa mi
voz me congela completamente bueno no lo
curioso es que es una noticia que vi
en aquí radio canadá sobre una que
sucedió el 3 de julio pasado y es de una
diplomática haitiana que trabajaba que
trabaja en la embajada de haití en
ottawa que estaba encinta y que estaba
cerca del parto no entonces pues tuvo
contracciones y era no era y todo lo
demás entonces como que cuando llegaron
otras contracciones
no lo tomo muy en serio dejó ir la cosa
y cuando de repente se dijo bueno ya es
hora de que vaya al hospital y salió del
apartamento y el niño nació en plena
calle
bueno no no no las escaleras se van
viendo en el pasto afuera del edificio
ahí nació el papa dice que el niño tocó
tierra a las nueve y veinte entonces
hubo todo un revuelo en el barrio había
un niño jugando
la mujer estaba gritando pidiendo ayuda
los vecinos salieron vinieron a
auxiliarla y bueno pese había una una
policía que vivía cerca y entonces los
niños fueron corriendo y dice a decirle
que estaban maltratando una mujer porque
estaba gritando ya entonces fue debido a
la policía en fin
me pareció curioso que como noticia no
es la primera vez que oigo hablar de un
parto he oído hablar de partos en carro
mientras que van al hospital pero así en
el pasto tan brutal de que el niño se
caiga no bueno al parecer pues diez días
más tarde el niño estaba en perfecto
estado de salud que está muy bien y la
familia está muy contenta y le agradece
pues a todos los vecinos que
concurrieron y que vinieron a prestarles
ayuda en ese momento tan tan difícil
bien a mí lo que me llamó la atención
gratamente fue la victoria de croacia
sobre la tierra
y también me parece muy buena esa
noticia sí así que yo creo que ya me
parece raro pues pero igual no sea por
quedar muy contento no digamos porque la
lógica del fútbol el dibujaba a otra
cosa pero bueno es que el fútbol tiene
lógico ahora no en verdad se está
terminando la lógica del fútbol no es
decir estamos todos muy contentos con
esta final que en realidad bueno yo
tengo la sensación de que va a ganar
francia y con deseos de que gane croacia
por una cuestión de que nunca ganaron la
copa del mundo llegaron solamente a una
semifinal y perdieron
o sea sería que amaron
[Música]
si llegaron lo más lejos fue las finales
contra francia entonces sería un poco
como bueno la concreción de este círculo
de la venganza deportiva al arrebato y
es que le ganaron a los ingleses ahora
porque además jugaron con mucha bronca
porque los ingleses se creían de tiempo
inglaterra no hizo tres goles más
displicentes si uno veía el partido de
ganas y se quedaba telar y tocaban
tocado en tocaban tocarme de patear
tocaban toca toca y eso pasó licencia lo
que encontraban sobradores exacto
entonces yo creo que éste esté así dejó
de superioridad que tuviéramos inglés en
el primer tiempo lo pasaron todas esas
corbatas acerquen qué manera de pelear
los croatas que jugaron ya dos porterías
de dos partidos con la larga y penal
si físicamente es como si hubieran
jugado un partido más que francia por 33
partidos que jugaron que fueron siempre
al suplemento es bueno porque fueron 90
minutos
además bueno yo estaba muy contento
porque inglaterra sacó a colombia si en
un contendiente mundial y estaba
contento que croacia ganar a inglaterra
a los colombianos los croatas pero
ustedes no escucharon a los argentinos
del consuelo ahora de los argentinos
bueno nosotros perdimos dos partidos en
el mundial y los perdimos con los dos
que llegaron a la final
campeón y mandó un cartelito diciendo
bueno en realidad estamos en la línea
las últimas los últimos tres campeonatos
que tiene perdido con el campeón verdad
amigos están escuchando las américas
café así que si ustedes tienen alguna
predicción si creen que creen que va a
ganar si será francia
entonces háganos saber alberto martínez
se nos cuenta que está viéndonos desde
nicaragua y que el clima también está
muy caliente en aquellos lugares y
gabriel infante carrillo dice saludos a
todos desde méxico mexicano estamos mkc
entrar a ver si tenemos algunos oyentes
porque tenemos oyentes en la argentina y
chile
entonces se manifiesten y también
teníamos gente que no sabía de españa y
una señora que nos ve junto al mar
que debe el clima de esa fantástico por
allá pues y con el arco del huracán
en la catástrofe de luge y después
la samba catástrofe año ahora bien
estamos ahora en la parte en que
nosotros les presentamos los temas que
recomendamos les recomendamos que
visiten nuestro sitio de internet y
empezamos contigo leonard porque tú no
sabrás de dos el volumen
si dos proyectos de google ex que se
transforman en compañías independientes
así es en realidad siguen todavía bajo
la lupa de google
bien entendido lo que pasa es que antes
eran proyectos dentro de un gran
proyecto llamado google x que tiene
proyectos que empiezan como startups y
bueno ahora les llaman de otra manera no
recuerdo bien el término
lo que pasó es que estos dos proyectos
particularmente han tomado el empuje
necesario entonces van a trabajar solos
ya tienen antes era un director el
director de google x que era el director
de estos dos proyectos ahora tienen si
cada uno de esos proyectos y van a
funcionar un poco más de costado y con
con buenos pronósticos los proyectos son
wink que es uno de los proyectos que
él tiene contemplado lograr el reparto
de mercancías lo que sea puntualmente
digamos han hecho tests con medicamentos
y comida a lugares que son remotos y
casi inaccesibles a través de drones y
lo que están generando también es un
mapeo de las rutas de los drones para
hacer una especie de mapa aéreo y hacer
un control de los drones por eso es uno
de los grandes otros que está haciendo
siete proyectos es amazon que no lo
puede registrar todavía porque hay un
problema con respecto a el uso del
espacio aéreo en este caso el wing está
haciendo eso y el otro es el un que es
el proyecto de estos
grandes globos que llevan internet
también a lugares de poco acceso que la
tecnología anormal en la tecnología
terrestre no puede llegar entonces esos
dos proyectos se desprenden de la gran
casa madre google x y se lanzan como los
proyectos no enteramente independientes
pero como se gradúan de proyectos en
serio si este google accedía alphabet
exacto exacto que tiene un montón en
realidad desde su mini la sextos y
subsidiarias tienen de test de
inteligencia artificial tienen robótica
tienen cálico que es el que estudia la
historia de de cómo el ser humano va
creciendo y se va poniendo viejo pero
que tratan de mejorar la calidad de vida
algunos dicen que están buscando la
inmortalidad pero bueno ese es otro de
los proyectos de otro cuentos chinos en
realidad es un cuento chino lo que están
haciendo es que sí porque él
evidentemente la vida se está estirando
para el ser humano normal
y lo que están tratando de hacer en este
proyecto cálico puntualmente es que la
vida a partir de los 70 años sea
productiva también y que nadie se
enferme porque es que cómo hacer para
que las células no se deterioren cómo se
deterioran normalmente por el paso del
tiempo o sea que esa idea de que habría
una sociedad en la cual los robots iba a
hacer todo en formación dedicarnos a la
pintura o aprender a ser pastelería
pero no no pero hay lugares si no me
equivoco en europa donde ya están
probando en ciertos poblados gente que
no trabaja ya la gente hace trabajos
comunitarios pero no tiene que ir a
trabajar para ganarse si no están
escuchando y ese eso es un pequeño
pueblo nos hiciese en noruega o en
finlandia noruega islandia donde el
gobierno decidió hacer un experimento
durante cinco años me parece que le
están dando dinero a la
gente de ese pueblo el equivalente a más
de lo que pueden necesitar un poco más
del salario mínimo digamos que pueden
vivir y la gente puede hacer lo que
quiera y lo que se dan cuenta es que hay
una mayor creatividad entrando y que por
ejemplo alguien que quería trabajar con
niños pues se da el lujo ahora puede
tener una guardería en su jardín a
ayudar a la gente hay una serie de cosas
que están haciendo música en desarrollar
todo el intercambio monetario digamos
que lo tienen no tienen que echar para
comer eso el mundo come todo el mundo
tiene habitación pero qué haces con tu
tiempo libre es la idea previsión de un
futuro donde hay un montón de elementos
que van a ser reemplazados por la
inteligencia artificial nuevo digital
entonces qué hacemos con toda esa gente
que no tiene empleo este es uno de los
proyectos y hay muchos en muchos
proyectos sociales que están
desarrollando ellos mismos entonces en
ese sentido se encuentro que es te da
tiempo para hacer cable que shrek y
mirarse ya entonces voy a hacerlo acá
[Música]
no es lo mismo estaba en irlanda por
ejemplo y allí ver la calidad del
transporte público es increíble es
trágico volver a montarla canadá pesado
en toronto estado de montreal y ver como
los seres humanos literalmente
prisionero en estas cajas de metal que
son los autos mientras que otros países
en europa tienen un sistema de
transporte buses trenes te doy un día en
buenos aires ya para que te habitúes
este sonido de la bolsa y méxico- la
bocina es veracidad es una rutina es que
cuando uno toca bocina se vuelve sé que
está pasando algo pasa o algo rápido
algo extraordinario y la razón en
argentina en el centro de las ciudades
más grandes
córdoba rosario buenos aires es
incesante a toda hora bocina bocina
bocina el [ __ ] como dice aquí
es completamente inhumano
ya entonces es el transporte público ese
es una solución para esos pitos bien
leonard a turnos a las del apoyo
canadiense que ha hecho posible el
acceso al agua potable instant a
clotilde si lo conversé con un organismo
o una organización no gubernamental
canadiense que se llama alas de
esperanza el presidente es andrew france
en realidad lo que me llamó la atención
aparte de que el objetivo de ellos
justamente es llevar agua potables a
poblaciones alejadas de los centros
urbanos en perú lo vienen haciendo desde
hace 50 años rufo lo que me llamó la
atención iban a lugares pequeños de con
pequeñas comunidades donde justamente
hay una necesidad muy grande de agua
potable y cómo trabajan y en realidad es
un trabajo interesante porque esta ong
es chiquita pero si trabajan en conjunto
con las comunidades es decir la gente
del lugar son los albañiles son los
arquitectos son
mujeres todo el mundo trabaja porque esa
es la base de tener éxito y lo están
logrando con pequeñas comunidades lo que
me llamó la atención de esto en santa
clotilde es la relación que tienen con
canadá y que viene desde hace muchísimo
tiempo han llevado agua a un centro
donde hay para escuelas y un hospital en
santa clotilde este hospital fue fundado
por un canadiense y un estadounidense
oblatos son sacerdotes hace 30 40 años
que crearon este hospital allí y lo
interés bueno y el sacerdote el nombre
de un oblato de la provincia de
saskatchewan es maurice scherer y el
seguro y en segundo lugar es las
escuelas estas escuelas fueron fundadas
por hermanas de la ciudad de sherbrooke
que estuvieron 50 años en ese lugar en
santa clotilde que han creado esas
escuelas y hoy esas escuelas están ya
hay una continuidad y que es la
garantiza la unas hermanas de mexicanas
de guadalajara y el tema del hospital
hoy está manejado por peruanos mismos
médicos pero todavía hay médicos
canadienses y estadounidenses que van de
vez en cuando a hacer sus trabajos
también ayudar entonces esa relación me
llama muchísimo la atención que se siga
manteniendo hoy y hoy este organismo ong
alas de esperanza está continuando con
ese trabajo entonces hay mucho en esta
entrevista que es con andrew francia que
me gustó muchísimo hacerla y pues está
en el sitio web para ver cómo trabajan
con las comunidades nuestro sitio
internet es hereje y net punto sea y tú
pablo no sabrás de que la calma ha
vuelto a haití tras protestas contra el
aumento del precio de los combustibles
sí recordemos que el sábado 7 de julio
hubo cuando se dio esta noticia cuando
el gobierno de joven el moi se anunció
algunos dicen que aprovechando el
mundial
exacto quería meter un gol olímpico y
anunció él
de los productos petroleros petroleros
que se venden de la gasolina todo lo que
se vende en las gasolineras y esto
provocó una ola de violencia
desenfrenada en haití el país fue
prácticamente saqueado a la gente salió
a las calles saquearon almacenes
quemaron autos un policía que iba por
ahí mal parqueado lolo lo agarraron lo
mataron y lo quemaron después ahí en el
pavimento entonces fue brutal como
reacción no y bueno pues ese salió
completamente de las manos del gobierno
la situación y al día siguiente el día
siguiente perdón fue el viernes cuando
ocurrió esto y al día siguiente al
sábado
el presidente joven el moisés salió en
la televisión pública decir bueno o sea
no vamos a aumentar la gasolina
lo que sí es para que ustedes se entren
a las casas y que la calma vuelva no
vamos a hacer ningún aumento y bueno
pues entonces estuve conversando con
francés voltaire que es el director del
centro de documentación internacional de
información haitiana caribeña y afro
canadiense entonces el francés decía que
finalmente el análisis que él hacía en
esta entrevista que hicimos es que es de
cierta forma el aumento del precio de la
gasolina fue como una especie de
pretexto finalmente pero que hay como
que la gota que desbordó
el vaso porque finalmente hay toda una
desesperanza en el pueblo haitiano desde
o sea que está siempre desposeído que
vive en la miseria mira sólo para dar
algunas cifras 10 del 10.4 millones de
haitianos de los cuales 6 millones o sea
59% de la población vive bajo el umbral
de la pobreza y ve y 22 puntos con 2.41
dólares diarios
además 2.5 millones viven bajo el umbral
de la pobreza extrema entonces esa
situación ha hecho que medidas como
entraron de haití para hacerse ricos
algunos aprovechan el bolsillo aún los
que están en el poder hoy en día que es
un gobierno corrupto un francés voltaire
lo dice en la entrevista entonces pues
dice de que ese es mientras que no sé no
sea no se establezca una conexión entre
las clases políticas y el pueblo
aumentarle con esas cifras que acabamos
de decir aumentar el precio de la
gasolina es volverle la vida imposible a
60 por ciento la población que ya vive
en la miseria si entonces pues es
interesante
pues la entrevista con france voltaire
está en nuestro sitio internet eres el
punto o sea aquí tenemos una persona más
que nos mandas al mensaje luis balderas
dice oyendo desde san antonio en chile
también gabriel infante carrillo que
dice saludos desde méxico a quienes nada
se pronuncian pidieron perdón ya
nicaragua también ya lo he visto y yo
les recomiendo este artículo sobre la
decisión del gobierno conservador de
ontario de abandonar el nuevo programa
de educación sexual y justamente la
victoria de los conservadores ha hecho
que justamente
eche para atrás una reforma una del
programa educación sexual en las
escuelas en el cual los niños podían
aprender por ejemplo sobre el ciberacoso
sobre el sexting y sobre todas estas
nuevas formas de interrelación que son
resultado de las nuevas tecnologías
entonces ahora el nuevo gobierno
conservador ha decidido que se archiva
ese plan y se vuelve al plan de
educación que estaba en vigor desde 1998
así que es un enorme debate porque
además esto se suma también el hecho de
tomar esa decisión y aunque haya una sí
por eso todo porque es un es una
cuestión pues que concierne a todas la
provincias y es una política del
gobierno provincial es baja tiene la
tiene digamos el poder para modificar
los programas de educación y esto
también hace parte es básicamente es una
es es un reflejo de la ideología
conservadora que por ejemplo
se pegó al cielo cuando empezaron por
ejemplo a hablar en los programas
educación a los niños sobre parejas del
mismo sexo sobre la identidad de género
lo único que faltaría es que quieran
volver atrás con la cuestión del aborto
también ya no ya y sobre la masturbación
que son cosas que es el imán hay que
hablar de eso claro parte de la
sexualidad no efectivamente y esto se
suma también y hay que añadir este el
hecho de que hay como pronto la ciudad
más grande del país
ontario donde hay casi 14 millones de
canadienses la más grande entonces
la inmigración también trae consigo
valores y hubo manifestaciones las
cuales sociedad emigrantes de sociedades
más conservadoras por el peso de la
cultura y la religión se oponen
justamente a ese tipo de educación lo
que no ven por ejemplo lastimosamente es
que los niños no van a vivir no viven en
sus países hoy no viven aislados acá tan
claro y están y eso provoca rupturas en
un momento dado entre los jóvenes y su
familia
independientemente de eso se siguen
viviendo en el seno de esa familia con
la cultura digamos de sus países pero
viven conocerán en la mano y el audio de
ahí tienen sus amigos canarias
no no no tiene ningún sentido pero lo
que pasará entonces en respuesta a algo
interesante es que una profesora decidió
que va a poner en internet y esto es
otra otro tema ya va a poner en las
redes sociales el programa entero un
nuevo programa para que tanto los niños
como los padres tengan acceso al ente
así que la informa de excelente de hacer
circular esta información y entonces
esos son los temas centrales que les
proponemos esta semana estarán
disponibles en nuestro sitio en internet
eres en el punto sea nuestra dirección
es siempre hablar
eres en punto sea y pueden siempre
enviarnos sus mensajes cartas y
sugerencias por correo cuanto más largo
mejor por aquí tenemos acá javi jefe que
dice en sintonía desde salinas ecuador
javier gonzález viejo oyente de la onda
corta y que ahora ya con alegría
un excelente sopa de panza de vaca
ya empezamos y ahora a esta hora de
hablar sí sí bien qué tal si antes de
despedirnos ya damos por lo menos
lectura a uno o dos mensajes ya que nos
quedan todavía unos tres o cuatro
minutos ya tengo acá uno de temas sobre
méxico tuvo más de 29 mil asesinatos en
2017 pero hay otras naciones con tasas
más elevadas exit describe víctor
buitrago buitrago y dice sin duda que el
narcotráfico y el desempleo hacen que
los índices sean altos en colombia y
brasil méjico le está quitando a
colombia el negocio de la droga y por
eso ha aumentado la tasa de homicidios
es increíble que panamá tenga un índice
tan alto casi igual al de colombia las
maras en el salvador hacen que los
ciudadanos no puedan ni siquiera salir a
las calles
los gobiernos latinoamericanos son
corruptos y entre más corruptos más
violencia sólo basta con darle una
mirada mexico colombia el salvador y
podemos asegurar que es así caso aparte
es venezuela que ya ni la cuentan en las
estadísticas pues ha sobrepasado
cualquier estimado o cifra razonable
esto nos dice víctor o muy trapo
si con respecto a la noticia violencia
en mexico golpe a las operaciones de una
minera de plata canadiense javier
gonzález mungaray nuestro amigo en
méxico dice desgraciadamente la
inseguridad y la violencia ya le quedó
grande a las autoridades municipales
estatales y federales para poder
controlar este mal en la sociedad
mexicana en mi caso aquí en guadalajara
hay gente que ya tiene miedo de salir a
las calles en la noche por la alta
inseguridad volviendo al tema es una
lástima que esta empresa canadiense esté
siendo afectada por ese problema espero
que no se retire de méxico en el
comentario de javier gonzález nunca hará
y yo aquí antes de leer el comentario
por el mensaje tengo aquí un pequeño
mensaje también de danielle camporini
que dice saludos desde monroe y danielle
dice yo soy viejo y antiguo lente
saludos paredes para para argentina
también en este caso yo tengo dice
canadiense de origen nicaragüense
crítica en el gobierno de ortega berta
caravaca garay dice bonjour por este
medio reconocemos el derecho de radio
canadá a reproducir y difundir esta
publicación y audio y en respuesta a ese
mensaje
anna soma arriba dice si el periodista
sentir la necesidad de hablar de la
inferencia de la cia y del
financiamiento del grupo armado de
derecha de la contra porque entonces no
mencionó la injerencia de la rss cuba
países del bloque del este y demás
interés e internacionalistas y además
porque calla todo el apoyo recibido por
el régimen de ortega por parte de chávez
para mantener este régimen afilado
afiliado al socialismo del siglo 21 ese
es el mensaje de anna somarriba a
nuestro sitio internet aquí tenemos un
mensaje de álvaro índice a propósito de
la orden de arresto contra rafael correa
ex presidente ecuatoriano habla de
conspiración abro dice sólo le faltó
indicar que el ex presidente correa le
acusan de ser el autor
intelectual del secuestro de un político
opositor el cual correa lo persiguió y
atacó de todas las formas posibles el
político se refugió en colombia donde
donde se lo intentó secuestrar los
sicarios contratados fueron apresados
por la policía colombiana y declararon
que fueron contratados por los miembros
de la secretaría de inteligencia del
ecuador
los ecuatorianos implicados fueron
apresados por la justicia ecuatoriana en
culpan a su jefe y éste a su vez a
correa esto no tiene nada de político y
la interpol no tiene razón para no
aceptar el pedido dice álvaro es en
respuesta a álvaro si me permites un
juego porque yo hice esa noticia no creo
que la haya leído totalmente a la
noticia porque efectivamente en la
noticia se hace mención a lo que él está
diciendo entonces que la vuelva a leer
aunque gates bien amigos entonces aquí
llegamos al final de este programa que
nada en las américas café sido un gusto
en estar con ustedes estaremos de
regreso la próxima semana hoy unos
micrófonos de honor a chapman pablo
gómez barrios leonardo gimeno y quienes
habla grupo valencia y nos vamos como
siempre con el tema de los
cuídense mucho un abrazo fuerte un
abrazo de dios